with respect to our race would it be
would it be a Bevin race if it wasn't a
squeaker I mean come on I mean really
and truly this is a close close race we
are not conceding this race by any
stretch
[Applause]
understand this we want the process to
be followed and there is a process we
know for a fact that there have been
more than a few irregularities they are
very well corroborated and that's all
right
what they are exactly how many which
ones and what effect if any they have
will be determined according to law
that's well established and just for the
record and some of you are well aware of
this four years ago I found myself in a
very similar situation again the law was
followed in that instance turns out that
it ended up being four tenths of a you
know four tenths of I get less for ten
and for ten thousandth of a percent or
whatever it was 83 votes my point is
this we want the process to be followed
the process will be followed and in the
end we will have the governor that was
chosen by the people of Kentucky and
that's the way the process should work
but let me say this you know it really
should and so no matter who it is no
matter who it is the people will know
with confidence that the process was
followed and to that end at the end of
the day regardless of R or D and again I
say this often and it's true in a room
of this size there's plenty of both in
here there's ours and E's here it says
n't